من منتجعه فيدورال توجه الرئيس السابق
دعون ترامب الى المحكمه في وسط ميامي ليست
المره الاولى التي يمثل فيها امام قادم
لكنها الاولى امام قادم فيدرالي ليواجه
سبعا
بحيازه وثائق سريه والتامر وعرقله العداله
داخل قاعه المحكمه وعبر محاميه لم يقر
ترامب بالذنب وبدا متجهما وجلس مكتوف
الايدي القاضي الذي اشرف على مثوله اصدر
قرارا بمنعه من التواصل مع والت نوتا
مساعده المتهم ايضا في القضيه كما طلب
قائمه باسماء شهود يمنع على ترامب التواصل
معهم
المشهد خارج المحكمه كان فوضويا مشادات ما
بين مناصر ترامب الذين يعتبرون ان القضاء
مزيف ضده ومناهضيه الذين يرون انهم انتهك
الدستور
بعد مغادرته المحكمه توقف في مطعم كوبي في
ميامي ليحيي مناصريه في مشهد حمل مفارقات
وبدا بعيدا عن جديه مادارا في قاعه
المحكمه ومن هناك توجه لمنتجعه في
نيوجيرسي ليلقي كلمه دافع فيها عن نفسه
تداوي ويندوز
شهدنا اليوم ابشع استخدام للسلطه في تاريخ
بلادنا ومن المحزن للغايه نرى رئيسا فاسدا
يعتقل خصمه سياسي بتهم ملفقه ومزيفه في
خضم انتخابات الرئاسيه ما يجري هو تداخل
في الانتخابات ومحاوله اخرى لتزويرها
وسرقتها انه اضطهاد سياسي كانه يحدث في
دوله فاشيه او شيوعيه سيذكر بايدن في
التاريخ كاكثر الرؤساء فسادا في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده
هذا وينتظر تحديد متى ستشرع وزاره العدل
في تقديم الادله التي استندت عليها في
توجيه التهم وكيفيه التعامل مع ما تشمله
من وثائق سريه والتوصل لقرار بشان موعد
المحاكمه في ظل طلب الادعاء بتسريعها
اتوقع ان تكون المحاكمه نهايه هذا العام
هذه ليست قضيه تشمل اسئله قضائيه معقده بل
يتم التركيز فيها على الحقائق على الاقل
فيما يتعلق بتهمه عرقله العداله وما اذا
كان هناك ادله مسجله على اشرطه
سجل مثول الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب امام محكمه فيدراليه سابقه تاريخيه
ليفتح الان فصل جديد من مجريات محاكمه
قضائيه بالتزامن مع مجريات حمله انتخابيه
ستكون على الارجح غير مسبوقه بسبب كويك
الجزيره ما يعني